all these models like in the Bahamas the
most insane festival the world has ever
saved island getaway turned disaster it
became very far bear just wait until you
see what you're getting yourselves into
American rappers our rule isn't the
Bahamas with his business partner really
McAuley it's an amazing entrepreneur he
could convince anyone it e much anything
they just bought an island Pablo
Escobar's Island oh my god we gotta talk
festival yeah didn't 48 hours they sold
out these guys are either completely
full of [ __ ] or their smartest guys in
the room we were working around the
clock no sleep Billy's like bring more
workers we need more workers every
single day guys more intense he just
would not take no for an answer and he
just kept pulling money in somehow
desperate people do desperate things he
was lying to investors and making it
seem like we were making a ton of money
you weren't I mean that's fraud we need
to get the messaging out now that this
is not a luxury music festival oh my god
there's mattresses all over the place
getting soaked the save yourself mode
kicked in right it's a free-for-all it
became this looting mentality there's an
angry mob they're pissed off and they
want their money powerful models built
this festival and then one picture of
cheese on toast ripped down the festival
they just couldn't physically fit that
many people on the island the events
co-founder is facing up to 20 years in
prison if you had thousands of dollars
the goat on a trip to see blink 182
that's on you that is Darwinism at its
finest the biggest event in decades I
promise you I'll be there
[Music]
you